o hoje em dia
saí de cerca de 10 dos milhões de jovens
no continente africano para o mercado de
trabalho
só que a economia digital exige algumas
competências bem específicas hoje em dia
que eles não têm
então como é que vamos apanhar esses
jogos porque só um terço deles é que vão
conseguir entrar no mercado de trabalho
formal
uma outra parte no mercado informal e
temos em áfrica uma penetração das novas
tecnologias como foi dado o exemplo do
dormir e à infraestrutura que está a ser
feita porque vamos importar ex patrão
para fazer o trabalho enquanto temos uma
já uma força de trabalho tão jovem
dinâmica que quer fazer isso então por
que não dar as competências necessárias
a esses jovens para trabalharem nesse
novo mercado
aqui só para dar uma idéia do contexto é
uma região com grande áfrica que dizem
tranqüila a china está lá dentro está a
transmitir frança índia quase podemos
ter toda a economia mundial a nível
geográfico
nós temos desafios também aqui uma
imagem é muito conhecida e eletricidade
a europa está a transmitir vez que a
áfrica está um pouquinho escura e claro
tenha efeitos a nível de escolaridade
entre as crianças não podem estudar à
noite
a nível de segurança mas o registo
também como uma oportunidade porque são
desafios que vão ser ultrapassados com
infra-estruturas os governos a investir
nisso
né eu vejo isso mais como oportunidade
são as crianças só nossa oportunidade
como é que vamos ver essas crianças um
período de dez ou mais anos tem mais no
futuro todas as competências que são
exigidas no século 21 são atingidas
nesta economia digital que eu está agora
a acontecer como já foi
as competências que só falar estão
dentro das áreas chamadas que o suzano
na crônica e skin itaporã em chico
science tecnology em dinheiro em off
mathematics mas dentro dessas áreas
todas
o importante é ter um pensamento crítico
saber resolver problemas comunicar se
apresentar bem e surge deixe saber
liderar e tomar responsabilidade não só
liderar os outros mas também saber
liderar a si mesmo o que podemos fazer é
pensar num ecossistema em que a
tecnologia e capital humano são muito
importantes para o nosso salvador
produções que vive nos estados unidos
conhece esse ecossistema muito
importante ter muitas ideias
a tecnologia tem de estar lá ou então em
vendas
o capital humano que é um fator muito
muito importante e depois financiamento
mas para ter financiamento é preciso ter
as outras três comissões porque um
financiador não vai investir numa ideia
não tem equipas opções suficientes para
executar a idéia
isso em qualquer parte né
se trouxermos está áfrica ou pode ser
cabo verde em qualquer país africano e
deixe temos muitas não falta deles
mesmo em casa não falo isso é uma coisa
que temos a tecnologia pode ser
importado fora também
nosso problema está no capital humano
está na capacitação das crianças dos
jovens que precisamos é aí que eu que eu
faço o meu foco sempre do meu trabalho
quando falo com os jovens em que
competência já que eles têm crise e em
que áreas
depois meu capital
queiram ou não queiram há dinheiro no
mundo para investir em boas idéias que
possam ser executados porque eu quero
focar na parte do capital humano
suder mãos das crianças hoje a
oportunidade de durante pelo menos cinco
a dez anos quando tiveram sortes nova
independentemente do que queiram ser
querem ser brasileirinhos que era ser
advogados querem ser médicos não precisa
ser todos os programadores e engenheiros
mas se tem essas competências não
interessa em que o mercado está vamos
ser competitivos no planeta no mundo
todo vão ser competitivos com qualquer
pessoa na china
qualquer pessoa na coréia do sul no
japão estados unidos ou na europa
daí saber as condições para não ter um
jogo bom em deus vou ficar cá porque
aqui estão os desafios e os problemas
que eles querem resolver
porque o foco nessa no capital humano
nos países desenvolvidos
temos uma grande quantidade de pessoas
formadas que podem executar as idéias
temos também pessoas que fazem a como só
que não temos em quantidade suficiente e
como viram muita fumaça fora e fico eu
sou um exemplo são um exemplo disso
hoje tento sempre fazer trabalhos fazer
visitas aos projetos em café da tô feliz
consigo realizar projetos em dólar hoje
é assim aos poucos passa passa mas para
conseguir enxergar o futuro para
conseguir aproveitar os dados aproveitar
das infra-estruturas aproveitar do
conhecimento que vai ver
temos que ter pessoas suficientes temos
formar em massa
criar um exército mesmo de pessoas
competentes para executar este diz que
qualquer um de vocês possam ter um
exemplo porque é muito importante
o plano da juventude é aplicar essa
juventude é muito dinâmica
hoje em dia estão com forma de aprender
e há muitas oportunidades aí se queira
saber são os meios são grandes
consumidores de conteúdo no sótão no
facebook ou não está caro consumir
conteúdo tem forma de informação e vou
dar zero sem haver ficamos de dormir
vamos passar à frente em alguns países
já está a acontecer é muito avançado
que aquilo é importante hoje em dia que
é que eles têm andado a fazer
eles têm nos ouvido problemas locais que
têm implicações globais jovem europa
está ou pode vir com uma ideia sobre uma
aplicação para resolver um problema
mesmo que humilde na sua comunidade que
não tem as possibilidades é muito
diferente porque há problemas
exemplos haver problemas com a água isso
pode ter um impacto global porque vai
ser uma coisa que hoje e no futuro vai
haver muita escassez
então vamos pensar nesse pleito eu vejo
algumas oportunidades aqui toda essa
camada jovem não sou jovem mas a
população está a crescer e viver em
muitas vão estar em grandes organizações
vamos ter os desafios e oportunidades a
nível de marketing de cidades
inteligentes nível da agricultura
sustentável
hoje em dia investe muito em muitos
países africanos em grandes em grandes
fazendas mas não se investe ainda tudo
na infraestrutura na plataforma
logística que eu digo por cada milhão
inverso não tem que investir 2 ou 3
milhões
outra pasta na área de inovação a nível
financeiro
sabiam que quase 80%
vou falar no geral a população ainda
subsariana não usa serviços bancários
a oportunidade não só para
empreendedores para universidades para o
governo tem tudo pra estar para terem
esse tipo de serviço
a nível de mobilidade claro quando um
grande número de pessoas na cidade
como é que vamos ver como é que vamos
organizar mudou
tudo isso depois usando as novas
tecnologias inteligência data tudo vai
vai ser no futuro e com quem é que vamos
fazer isso vamos ter que formar os
nossos jovens para resolver os problemas
porque eles é que vão experimentar esse
problema não é uma pessoa que vem de
fora e impõe uma solução não eles quando
puser em quando encontrarem solução vai
ser a solução mais ótima
alguns exemplos de inovação não
acontecerem em que recebia de partilhar
com vocês uma dessas do de centros é o
quênia e outro na jogada correta é um
encubadora semanas em incubadoras de 6
3%
fala de instrumento mas tem pessoas que
acreditam que este instrumento já até
conseguir alguma coisa e vai pro mercado
então tem conhecimento dele no mestre é
um lugar onde eu estou formação durante
dois anos a empreendedores quando
cheguei lá e comer e de negócio ou mesmo
já consegue nossa feita às grandes
empresas
hoje em dia já estão a investir muito em
inovação em abril está acontecendo não
só microsoft aí vemos já tem um centro
de pesquisa e 9 general electrics tem um
centro de inovação na áfrica do sul
e aí vem a também já tem os seus centros
de investigação ao seu lado se não me
engano
isso é na áfrica do sul
o mundo é dada oportunidade aos jovens é
preciso ser jovem basta ter uma idéia e
executar teve a oportunidade de
experimentar para ver se criar um
produto típico de ver se consegue sido
publicado
o mais rapidamente possível
queria partilhar com o vasco
esta iniciativa a tony e modelo não sei
se alguém aqui já ouvi falar dele mas
criou uma fundação a nigéria que quer
encontrar 10 mil empreendedores em dez
anos
em todos os países africanos e a ideia é
conseguir através dessa iniciativa criar
um milhão de postos de trabalho
fiquei um pouco decepcionado ao ler o
relatório de impacto de cabo verde só
mandou uma aplicação
nossa isso é porque não foi muito bem
mas é muita pena isso é a oportunidade
que todos os anos durante dez anos
começou em 2015
foram dez anos vai todos os anos
por isso para quem tem desde quem quer
experimentar e isso é um é panafricano
sei que vais encontrar pessoas de outros
países onde pode criar uma network para
fazer os seus negócios e porque aquilo
que disse não vou dizer por que mas às
vezes as pessoas por aqui um kart eu saí
investir 100 milhões de dólares nesse
programa
eu também se tivesse dinheiro e investir
melhor porque está à espera do ter que
isso possa ajudar looks de 10 milhões
claro que eu também tivesse milhões ea
polícia para fazer isso tudo é preciso
ter uma equipe que o conceito de scan é
o que quero utilizar aqui mas é a equipa
tem que ser bem integrada precisam de
mentor precisam de investidores precisam
de pessoas do partido que partilhem
conhecimento dos mentores tudo isso
então esse conselho dos cantores têm que
ir de uma forma bem integrada
para resumir gosto desse culto do
confúcio é só na última na última frase
o que eu disse ter um plano para 100
anos
invista nas crianças é o que eu é uma
coisa que eu concordo muito que levo
sempre comigo quando show falar com os
jovens
ao pedir um conselho de sido cash
escreveu num pedaço de papel
faça um plano depois pago país precisa
quer dizer trabalho duro até atingir
depois não há limite
eu acho que nós temos grandes desafios
pela frente e grandes oportunidades
por isso eu peço meu carro technology de
uma menina né
é pedir a todos que participem nessa em
criar esse ecossistema princípio em
criar esse ecossistema que deixa de
destruir e que encontrem as pessoas que
discutem
acreditem nas suas que queiram fazer que
assume o risco para os que podem
influenciar financie prusch podem ser
mentores sejam ventoso juntas isso
queria agradecer ao técnico
[Aplausos]
ae